[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay en tant qu'aménageur
maîtres d ouvrage des espaces publics de
ce qu'on appelle le sud plateau est
générateur de mouvements de terre donc
il est paru nécessaire assez rapidement
de mettre en place des filières qui
éviterait une évacuation par camion de
ses stocks et donc ses stocks là qu'on a
mélangé avec du compost afin de rendre
ces lits mon inerte fertile ceci nous a
permis d'éviter une évacuation durant
cinquante mille mètres cubes de limon
par camion en dehors du plateau c'est
cette terre végétale nouvellement créée
qui a pouvoir maintenant être très
employé dans les espaces verts des
différents quartiers du plateau de
saclay nous avons tout d'abord commencé
le chantier en 2019 par une
caractérisation des des terres c'est à
dire qu'on est venu sur site pour
réaliser des sondages et définir en fait
le les différents matériaux qu'on
pouvait trouver sur ce site on y
installer un atelier de tri avec des
pelles mécaniques pour reformer des
cordons choix de limon qui sont
réutilisables soit de matériaux argileux
puisqu'ici on a beaucoup d'argile à
meulières non réutilisables donc ces
matériaux une fois validé par la
maîtrise d'oeuvre sur le paysage
nous les avons pour les bons matériaux
ramener ici sur cette cette aire de
stockage en collaboration avec
l'entreprise nous avons élaboré cette
plateforme sur laquelle nous nous
trouvons cette plateforme est également
le lieu ou n'a pu constituer les mélange
de terre amendes et avec du compost
puisque la fabrication de substrats
fertile repose sur le principe de
mélange de terre faiblement organique
avec du compost de déchets verts
en proportion est en caractéristiques
maîtrisé puis ces matériaux vont évoluer
sous couvert végétalisée comme on peut
le voir sur la plateforme et
le matériau va évoluer par bio turba
sion c'est à dire que le système
racinaire va permettre une aération et
une amélioration du matériau sous jacent
donc du coup toute cette toute cette
table de culture
va pouvoir va pouvoir servir desservir
tous les chantiers qu'il ya sur le
plateau de saclay côté palaiseau
polytechnique où nous l'ont qui est de
l'autre côté
ce projet de remédiation des termes des
terres inertes en terre fertile a été en
partie subventionné par l'ademe pour sa
démarche innovante dans laquelle le pea
ps s'inscrit
[Musique]